[Music]
at the end of the 19th century the
cigarette existed at the center of a lot
of different cultural forces the one
you're looking at right here is from a
painting by Edvard mook most famous for
another canvas called
the screen this self-portrait with
cigarette made two years later though
less jarring is just as concern with
monks personal psychology and the dark
underside of his identity as the
Screamers but to his critics in his
hometown of Oslo the portraits dark hazy
unfinished feeling was not only unfit
for art it was dangerous to the
psychology of the city and the age as
monks self-portrait demonstrates he is
by no means a normal man when an artist
is abnormal a shadow is thrown over all
his art that's a quote by Johann
Scharffen Berger Norwegian medical
student who was echoing a line of
conservative moral thinking that feared
the decay of society resulting from art
like that monk and his contemporaries
were making this pessimistic attitude
was popularized in a large book called
degeneration by this guy Max Nordau who
attacked pretty much every kind of art
that wasn't up to his moral standards as
poisonous and corrupting for Scharffen
Berger Nordau the cigarette was
symptomatic of society's degeneration it
was along with alcohol one of
civilizations ugly indulgences
but for MOOC and his circle of decadent
artists the cigarette was something much
different for them the end of the 19th
century also represented a change but it
was a chance for a break from the stale
bourgeoisie values the prudish and
uptight conservative values of Nordau
and his acolytes in 1890s Europe the
cigarette still wasn't all that popular
only ten years earlier James Albert von
sack invented a rolling machine which
made it possible to mass-produce
200 cigarettes a minute but they were
still dwarfed by the sales of cigars and
pipes since the beginning when beggars
in Spain took the discarded tobacco from
cigar butts and
them the cigarette had always been
associated with the lower classes in the
Crimean War soldiers rolled tobacco and
old newspapers by the 1890s when machine
made cigarettes were cheaper to produce
and by the working classes of Europe
began adopting the cigarette while the
middle class especially the men stuck to
their cigars this lithograph by theophil
Stein hland captures the feeling
perfectly
notice how the bush huazi man clad in
his proper dress and hat uses his cigar
to light the cigarette for the man with
the loose collar who is clearly of a
lower social standing it was in the
lower classes that monk and his bohemian
contemporaries found their alternative
to the suffocating middle-class value
system they traded in drawing rooms for
late-night cafes dinner parties for
nightclubs and cigars for cigarettes
cigarettes became the essential prop up
the bohemian lifestyle in this painting
by mentor Christian Crowe you can see a
21 year old Edouard monk lighting up
with his friends and fellow painters in
his studio in this etching by monk
himself
smoke snakes and fills up the atmosphere
of a cafe where bohemian intellectuals
of both genders drink and debate art and
ideas in other words everything Max
Nordau despised as critic Patricia
Berman notes Bohemians of the 1880s and
1890s embraced the deviancy that people
like Nordau assigned to them they
existed somewhere between the middle
class and the anarchy of the streets and
their aesthetic revolt was the birth of
what we can see now was cigarette cool
for monks work this meant moving away
from the naturalism of his predecessors
the scientific recording of the natural
world even moving away from
Impressionism which monk saw as little
more than formal exercises with light
his task would be to dig into his own
psyche and record subjective experience
that's how you get something as
terrifying as The Scream this is how
dark subjectivity warps the natural
world as he wrote later I was walking
along the road with two friends the Sun
was setting suddenly the sky turned
blood-red I paused feeling exhausted and
leaned on the fence there was blood and
tongues of fire above the blueblack
fewer
and the city my friends walked on and I
stood there trembling with anxiety and I
sensed an infinite scream passing
through nature you read any diary or
memoir of a sufferer of depression and
you'll find similar moments of
disturbing transformation the truth is
that mental illness was underscoring
this whole transitional time in history
as nations came to grips with the rapid
growth of anxiety depression mania and
other mental illnesses different groups
reacted in different ways it's what's
really at the heart of Nordau spheres of
degeneration
it's what a number of bohemian artists
of the era were attempting to explore in
their work the tragic relationship
between madness and creativity is
undeniable
some ran from that fact others refuse to
look away at this time there was a kind
of catch-all term that's no longer
really in use neurasthenia something
that's probably more akin today to acute
anxiety or mild mania and here too the
cigarette is significant because there
was a belief floating around that
cigarette smoking was one of the causes
of insanity a theory put forward in a
book by dr. L Bremer called tobacco
insanity and nervousness another doctor
the surgeon Theodore Bill Roth believed
that the widespread cases of
neurasthenia and neuroses were quote due
to alcohol and cigarettes now if you
look again at monks self-portrait with
cigarette you can see a nexus of all
these social constructions monk is aware
of his critics their belief in his
degeneration and the cigarette as one of
its causes he uses it as a formal reason
why the painting is nebulous it's
shrouded in cigarette smoke but he's
also using this dissolution by way of
cigarette to signal the intersection
between bohemian life mental illness and
art the prevalence of mental illness its
connection with genius and the failure
of Bush was demoralizing to come to
grips with these realities he encoded
the cigarette as a complex symbol
through which he asserted his complex
identity and created a site of
recognition for those who suffer today
because the problem mental illness has
only grown and its growth has
- and we're not that much more
enlightened as to its causes than we
were then but I think that monks work is
a consolation because it proves that our
confusion about mental illness in
medicine and science will always be
matched by a probing and nuanced
understanding in art of all kinds
hey everybody thanks for watching
welcome to my new apartment in Los
Angeles I just moved down here a couple
days ago with my girlfriend and it's
actually our one-year anniversary today
so if you're watching this actually
you're definitely watching this because
we're in the other room watching this
together right now I love you so much
happy Anniversary it's been the best
year of my life and you're the best
person that I've ever known and I'm
definitely not going to choke up on this
end screen so I'll just close it here by
saying I'll see you guys next Wednesday